the movie is set in Japan in the year
2030 because of a sudden decline in the
global oil production prices of
Commodities have risen steeply and the
domestic unemployment rate is the worst
since the end of World War II in short
Japan is undergoing a hyper recession
period which has brought turmoil all
over the country at the start of the
movie a news broadcast shows people
protesting against the increasing prices
in the country people have been forced
to leave their homes as they don't have
any source of income because of the
rising unemployment meanwhile at the
government employment office we are
introduced to the protagonist umoto just
like everyone else umoto has also been
badly impacted by the current crisis he
asks the job placement officer for a
suitable job but unfortunately there
isn't one it turns out that this has
been yamoto's fourth visit to the office
this week as he argues with the officer
for a job the lights suddenly go out
this shows how critical the situation of
the country has become later a
devastated yumoto wanders around a park
and stumbles across a statue of a peeing
boy the words useless guy have been
scribbled on the Statue and seeing this
Yamoto relates it to himself he then
takes out a handkerchief and begins
erasing the words after he's cleaned up
the whole statue he gets a sudden urge
to pee and rushes to find a bathroom
meanwhile the statue boy mysteriously
pees a drop of dark substance from its
wiener as if yumoto has summoned a Genie
in the next scene yumoto finally finds a
bathroom but when he enters he is
disappointed to find that they're not in
use anymore despite no one being around
and the place still being a bathroom he
chooses not to pee as the Japanese are
very strict with their manners however
when his urinary bladder reaches its
limit he forgets all of his ethics and
goes to a nearby Bush to relieve himself
there he notices a fire and decides to
extinguish it with his pee claiming that
it is dangerous for nature surprisingly
when he starts in instead of p a dark
substance comes out of his manhood as
soon as the liquid touches the fire it
bursts into large Flames as if the
liquid is combustible here it is finally
revealed that the peeing boy statue has
rewarded yumoto with a unique ability
for his kindness he can produce an
unlimited amount of oil just by peeing I
haven't seen pee this valuable since
Trump visited Russia startled by the
strange incident Yamoto immediately
heads to a doctor to get examined he
provides a sample of his urine and after
inspecting it the doctor is taken aback
Yamoto inquires if everything is fine
but the doctor simply asks him to wait
and goes outside after a while he brings
two men to the place and points them
towards yumoto the men are from the
national Research Institute and they are
there to escort yumoto to their
laboratory for research umoto tries his
best to convince them that he is a
normal person and that he just wants to
go home but the men drag him to their
van on their way to the lab Yamoto again
gets a southerner urged to pee and
requests one of the men for a break this
time his request is granted and the van
stops near a secluded Forest soon yumoto
starts peeing on a tree while the man
keeps an eye on him just then yumoto
notices that his pee is flowing in the
direction of the man at the same time
the man takes out a cigarette and as he
is about to light it he accidentally
drops his lighter unfortunately for him
the burning lighter falls directly into
yamoto's pee causing a large fire the
man is covered in flames and hearing his
screams his colleague rushes to help him
Yamoto is shocked to witness all this
but nonetheless he takes advantage of
the opening and makes a run for it after
running the whole night Yamoto arrives
at a small village the following morning
and collapses to the ground just then a
village girl comes across his pitiful
State and takes him home when he regains
Consciousness he finds an old man
staring at him startled Yamoto
immediately gets up and inquires about
the man's identity and the latter
replies that he is the man heir of the
village meanwhile the same girl who
brought Yamoto to the place jiaoku
enters the room with some food she is
the mayor's assistant and is one of the
most beautiful girls in the village as
soon as Yamoto sees the food he starts
devouring it as he hasn't eaten in a
whole day later the mayor along with his
group takimoto to the Village fields
which have become completely Barren he
explains that after the country started
going through hyper recession the
farmers couldn't afford oil and thus the
farming tractors were no longer operable
because of this The Village which was
once a very productive farming area has
now become deserted time for yumoto to
whip it out the mayor also reveals that
most of the youths in the village have
fled to Tokyo for a better life and now
All That Remains are old people and
cattle hearing all this yumoto becomes
sad he remembers the saying with great
power comes great responsibility because
he's a Spider-Man Stan and decides to
test himself out he excuses himself
picks up an empty bottle and heads
inside the nearby Woods as the mayor and
jaoku watch in suspense Yamoto starts
peeing inside the bottle and once again
he discharges oil seeing this the mayor
immediately covers jakku's eyes after
Yamoto is done he pours the collected
oil into the tractor and starts the
engine surprisingly the tractor comes to
life leaving the mayor and his group
stunned Yamoto then bids goodbye to the
group and prepares to leave however the
mayor requests him to stay in the next
scene Yamoto is taken to the Village
School where he is offered a job at
first he thinks that he will become a
teacher but when the mayor shows him his
empty basement-like room he becomes
confused soon the mayor introduces him
to sumiko the school caretaker who will
now assist Yamoto in his job the job is
simple all he has to do is drink a lot
of water and urinate Yamoto is initially
skeptical about the job but since he has
nowhere else to go he accepts next we
see an inspiring Montage of Yamoto
drinking water and filling several
gallon jars with his pee as he does his
business sumiko notes down his
performance and smiles like a proud
teacher by the end of the day he has
accumulated 30 jars of pee prompting the
mayor and his men to burst into Applause
Yamoto is happy as for the first time in
his life he has done something useful
because of his heroics the whole village
comes back to life the farmers start
harvesting the crops in their fields and
public buses are in full operation from
one of the buses two women come out and
start talking about the miraculous
discovery of oil in their Village they
also talk about how their Village is the
only one to not suffer power outages
yumoto who has also come out of the same
boss overhears their conversation and
smiles they can thank my balls for that
thanks Yamoto later he returns to his
office and starts his usual business
after a few hours he completes his quota
of 100 liters and decides to leave but
just then the mayor arrives and orders
him to produce more oil by this time
greed has set into his mind and he wants
more oil for himself hearing this yumoto
claims that he is already tired but the
mayor forces him to start peeing in the
evening yumoto meets with jaoku and the
two talk about their daily lives when
Yamoto reveals that he is working extra
shifts jiaoku mentions that the mayor is
cunning and that she doesn't like him
however she says that Yamoto is doing a
great job by helping the villagers
meanwhile at the school a delegate from
the national Research Institute Shinji
arrives and confronts the mayor he warns
the old man to reveal whatever he is
hiding since the village has been
producing a lot of oil lately however
the mayor who is unfazed by the threats
replies that he doesn't have anything to
hide with this Shinji leaves but not
before promising to come back again
elsewhere as Yamoto and sumiko go on
their daily work the power suddenly goes
out as a result yumoto decides to take a
break and heads to explore the other
rooms in the school when Yamoto gets a
little further he notices a few drops of
oil on the floor shocked he follows the
droplets and reaches a warehouse which
has several barrels of the oil stored in
it in the next scene an enraged Yamoto
confronts the mayor for his lies and
demands answers to his surprise the
mayor mentions that it's all business
and that he was just storing the oil to
sell to other cities I mean yeah what
did Yamoto think he was doing hearing
this Yamoto becomes even more angry and
decides to head down to the warehouse to
retrieve the oil and distribute it
amongst the villagers however before he
can proceed he is captured by the
mayor's men while being taken away he is
devastated to learn that sumiko knew
about the secret all along later yumoto
is tied up in an isolated room and
ordered to continue draining the Sea
Dragon when he refuses the men attach a
pipe to his manhood hoping that his pee
will get collected in a jar they then
warn him that if he holds his pee for
too long he might suffer from urinary
tract infection after the men leave
yumoto tries his best to hold his pee
but with each passing minute it becomes
increasingly difficult soon he reaches a
point where he simply can't hold it in
anymore but just then jaoku arrives at
the scene and rescues him she then tells
him that they must escape the place as
soon as possible wasting no time yumoto
gets up and the two run into the woods
after a while the mayor and his men
catch wind of the escape and immediately
begin a search operation upon reaching
the woods he finds some oil in a tree
and deduces that it must have come out
of yumoto the mayor then provides the
oil sample to his dog who in turn starts
tracking The Runaway couple elsewhere
yumoto and zhaoku reach an abandoned
house where they light a fire and start
an awkward conversation joku mentions
that the villagers are completely
dependent on yamoto's pee and that
they're willing to swallow it if that's
the only way to preserve it hearing this
Yamoto becomes sad and he blames himself
for bringing hope to the villagers he
then starts punching himself in the deck
hoping to destroy his oil tank however
joku stops him and asks him to save the
world with his pee she also mentions
that he is the chosen one whose P has
the ability to change people's lives the
speech finally inspires yumoto and he
agrees to stop bagging himself
aggressively and instead use his pee for
the betterment of humanity following
this the duo start making out don't get
too excited yumoto we don't know what's
going to come out of there while they
are busy we see a drop of oil appearing
out of nowhere and dropping into the
fire the next morning as the couple is
still asleep the mayor and his men
arrive at the place they immediately
wake the duo up and apprehend them as
they are about to leave Shinji suddenly
barges into the house with several armed
officers he then threatens the mayor to
hand yumoto over to him but the latter
refuses the mayor then reveals that his
plan was to produce large amounts of oil
so that his village can become an
independent country and he will become
the King on the other hand Shinji
mentions that the national Research
Institute is after yumoto as they want
to research him and create several other
oil-producing humans if they succeed in
this they can sell the oil at a high
price and rule the world in other words
everyone is greedy for yumoto's PP
meanwhile Yamoto becomes disgusted after
hearing the fantasies of both parties
having had enough he breaks free from
his captors and tells everyone that oil
is not there to make ugly fights with
people instead oil exists to make
everyone happy saying this much he picks
up a burning stick from the fire and
points it at Shinji at first Shinji is
unbothered as he believes that Yamoto is
fighting a failing battle however when
the oil man whips it out everyone in the
room is terrified they plead with him to
stop but Yamoto pees on the burning
stick surprisingly instead of exploding
the place the P extinguishes the fire
shocked yumoto tries one more time but
again the same result with this he
realizes that his superpowers have
finally come to an end realizing the
truth the mayor and Shinji also decide
to become friends as there is nothing
left to fight for the scene then Cuts
forward several years where Yamoto is
still in the village working as a
counselor he has married joku and the
couple has a son together the movie ends
as their infant son pees a mysterious
liquid which looks like a portal to
another dimension
what subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching